Speaker 1: Yesterday was truly a day for the
history books in the United States.
There aren't that many days every decade,
never mind century like what we saw yesterday.
The failed former President Donald Trump was
arrested, booked, indicted and pleaded not
guilty for 37 felony counts, was instructed
not to be in contact with any other defendants
nor witnesses, a requirement which he immediately
broke last night.
Trump then flew back to his Bedminster, New
Jersey, golf resort.
I think it is where he actually admitted to
some of the crimes that he is accused of,
despite claiming total innocence and claiming
that he didn't do anything.
And we now move into two different new phases,
the pretrial phase with this latest federal
indictment, as well as the waiting game for
what may be a second federal indictment for
Trump's role in the January six Trump riots
and a state indictment out of the state of
Georgia for Trump's attempt to incorrectly
fraudulently, illegally overturn the correct
results from Georgia in 2020, in which now
President Joe Biden won the popular vote of
Georgia and subsequently the electoral votes
from Georgia.
So let's start at the beginning.
The Miami Herald reporting Trump sits silently
in Miami Courtroom Pleads Not Guilty in Historic
Case.
Former President Donald Trump pleaded not
guilty Tuesday in Miami federal court to a
37 count indictment, accusing him of deliberately
keeping at his Palm Beach state government
documents that contained highly sensitive
defense weapons and nuclear information and
of obstructing efforts by U.S. authorities
to reclaim them in a packed courtroom.
And remember, there were no cameras in the
courtroom.
So all we have are these descriptions.
In a packed courtroom, Trump and Trump entered
his plea in a historic case marking the first
federal prosecution of a former president
and a potential hurdle in his renewed quest
for the presidency in the 2024 election.
Trump's lawyer, Todd Blanch, representing
Trump alongside Chris Keys, said, quote, We
most certainly enter a plea of not guilty.
Trump was arraigned a day before his 77th
birthday.
That will be relevant later as well.
Appearing before Magistrate Judge Jonathan
Goodman.
Trump said nothing during the 45 minute proceeding.
Prosecutor David Harbach told the judge his
team would prepare a list of witnesses with
whom Trump cannot communicate about the case
before the trial.
Trump was released on his own recognizance
with no monetary bond and no travel restrictions.
So I think it's important to mention one of
the reasons that this indictment generally
is important is that we want a justice system
that doesn't have exceptions where no one
is above the law.
And despite what you're hearing from the maggots,
Macedonians, MAGA, paté, Mayans, whatever
you want to call them.
Despite what you're hearing from them, that
this is evidence of a two tiered justice system
in a bad way.
In fact, we know we have a two tiered justice
system.
Trump being indicted is maybe a slight half
step in the direction of no one is above the
law.
However, there still are favorite isms that
are being given to Trump, including the fact
that he was released on his own recognizance
with no monetary bond as well as no travel
restrictions.
Many other defendants, not former presidents
of the United States.
By the way, individuals without private jets
with which they could fly anywhere at any
time would have been given a monetary bond
and may have had travel restrictions put in
place.
So just something to keep in mind.
The Associated Press also reporting they have
an interesting drawing of what the scene in
the courtroom looked like.
Trump reportedly looking glum and having his
arms crossed at many moments during this,
writes, Trump approached his arraignment with
characteristic bravado, posting social media
broadsides against the prosecution from inside
his motorcade en route to the courthouse and
insisting that he has done nothing wrong and
was being persecuted for political purposes.
We are going to discuss that.
But the article writes Inside the courtroom,
he sat silently, scowling and arms crossed
as a lawyer entered a not guilty plea on his
behalf in a brief arraignment that ended without
him having to surrender his passport, etc.,
etc.
Always in campaign mode, he swiftly pivoted
from a solemn courtroom to a festive restaurant,
stopping on his way out of Miami.
At Vici, an iconic Cuban spot where listen,
we'll talk about this later.
But they sang Happy birthday to Trump.
Trump turning 77 today and also prayed over
Trump, which was really quite a scene.
What we are going to look at today and much
of today's program will be related to the
fallout from this arrest, admittedly, and
we will talk about other issues as well.
And then tomorrow we will move on.
Part of today's program is going to look at,
number one, why is Trump defending himself
on the basis of a different set of restrictions,
the Presidential Records Act, rather than
the Criminal code than that under which he
has been charged?
We are going to discuss that.
Why is Trump admitting to having done many
of the things that he is accused of doing
in the indictment?
Well, it's because he thinks that that's actually
a defense of sorts.
And maybe most importantly at this point in
time politically for the United States, is
this.
The get out of jail free card that some Republicans
have been waiting for to say this is too much.
We can no longer support this man for many
Republican elected officials.
This is that moment for others like Marjorie
Taylor, GREENE, Lauren Boebert and other people.
It is not.
And they are steadfast, steadfast in their
support.
And lastly, what about your average Trump
supporter while Luke Beasley was on the ground
for us in Miami yesterday interviewing a number
of the several hundred, maybe most a thousand
people who came out to support Trump in Miami.
So we are going to get to all of that.
But let's start with Trump's own speech
after
the arrest,